one of the few topics that we have left
a discussing world of war are the
Valkyries the spirits who would take the
Honorable dead to Valhalla very early on
and go to war we see the data refusing
to remain dead because Helheim is full
and cannot house any more Souls we find
out that this is because the Valkyries
have not been performing their duty in
faerie Denis souls to Valhalla and like
most things in game Odin appears to be
behind it all
when Kratos anyt Reyes first encountered
the Valkyries we see that they have been
trapped in a physical form they appear
wild and driven by rage but when these
physical forms are destroyed they return
to their natural spirit state to a very
little memory of what had happened to
them over the course of the game you
come across each Valkyrie as somewhat of
a mini-boss freeing them from their
physical form and learning more each
time about how they were trapped and why
when we encounter the loss of the
Valkyries cygwin who assume the role of
leader she explains her through the use
of an archaic piece of magic Odin
corrupted the Valkyries in her attempt
to contain her sisters she imprisoned
them in places where they could cause
the least amount of harm but she herself
eventually fell victim to Odin's sorcery
its then revealed to us that the queen
of Valkyries is and has always been
Freya and potiphar agreement in her
marriage to Odin assigned to the role of
overseeing the Valkyries but Odin would
eventually take these Valkyrie wings
away from her
Mamiya then mentions that she came to
him looking for information on where
olden may have hidden her wings so there
is a possibility that we may see Freya
in her Valkyrie form pretty soon so now
that we've covered the story of the
Valkyries in God of War I'm sure many of
you want to know how they appeared in
traditional Norse mythology the
Valkyries were the female spirits that
will assist Odin and choosing which of
the Dead will take into Valhalla and the
name in Old Norse was thought to mean
choosers of the Fallen the modern image
we have of the Valkyries consists of
beautiful and elegant women who would
take dead heroes to Valhalla and though
to a certain extent this may be correct
it's a fairly selective portrayal
choosing to exaggerate the pleasant
qualities while ignoring the not so
pleasant qualities there are much older
depictions of the Valkyries where they
appear to be far more sinister and as
their name would suggest choosers of the
Fallen refer to them chosen who died in
battle through the use of malicious
magic they were able to ensure that
those who were chosen suffered the
desired fate it's because of this the
Valkyries have been likened and compared
to the Gita's or the karez of Greek
mythology
spirits that had rain of a malicious and
cruel death
perhaps the most graphic description of
the Valkyries gruesome sight can be
found within a poem in the saga of neon
where before a battle the tall Valkyries
are sitting in a loom weaving the tragic
destiny of the Warriors for thread they
used intestines severed heads for
weights and swords and arrows for
beaters while they chanted their horrid
intentions for the Warriors with an air
of delight to their voice so this image
of Valkyries being slightly malicious
and bloodthirsty is one Kalla for Pierce
were taken from their eldest depictions
in the sources that later followed the
Valkyries are mostly seen as elegant
women who served odin transport and his
favorites amongst of slain to Valhalla
where they would reside until the day
they were called upon to fight by Odin's
sight during Ragnarok in regards affray
had been seen as the queen of the
Valkyries that is something that appears
to remain unique to God of War as in
Norse mythology the Valkyries and Freya
appear to have no relationship whether
you believe the Valkyries of malicious
spirits who thrived on death and war or
elegant women who had affairs with men
and served odin they almost always
associated of bloodshed fairness and
destiny there are even those who see the
Valkyries as an extension of projection
of a part of Odin much like his two
Ravens Hugin and muninn if you have any
thoughts on the Valkyries or topics
you'd like to see covered in future
videos then let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained